across the country
ordinary americans from all walks of
life are taking whatever measures
necessary to prepare i'm preparing my
family for the total destruction of the
power grid the yellowstone super volcano
a financial collapse and protect
themselves and survival's the goal it's
into the spider hole go fast fast fast
fast fast
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
what i'm gonna use
like this
next we go inside the lives of three
committed preppers who have devised
extensive plans there's some 600 tons of
reinforcing steel in this structure gone
to great lengths we'll know when the
government takeover has happened when
they actually knock on your door
and made huge personal sacrifices to
ensure their very survival i've given up
being
socially acceptable the experts will
assess their extreme preps and decide if
they have what it takes to face
armageddon what wouldn't you do to
protect your family
and to survive dude you got fire this is
doomsday preppers
over 20 years ago michael james patrick
douglass left the marine corps and
settled in augusta maine in search of a
simpler life
now he's a wilderness school instructor
and lives on a 30-acre farm with his
wife and three kids where he's treated
his battle fatigues for homemade
buckskin and fast food for found food
this little groundhog a car took him out
if the hairs pop right out between the
shoulder blades the meat's too far gone
so i won't take it let's go eat
i've given up being socially acceptable
guess what i got
groundhog
so who wants some groundhog all right
the reason i came to maine was to get
away from it all
i'm preparing for overpopulation to
reach critical mass
the global population first reached 1
billion in 1804
in only 200 years the global population
has soared from 1 billion to 7 billion
researchers believe that the planet can
only sustain a limited number of people
and michael fears that we are fast
approaching critical mass and will soon
exceed the world's human carrying
capacity
overpopulation reaches critical mass
soils will be depleted and turn into
deserts
once those deserts establish themselves
it's irreversible
giant dust clouds turning the sky red
for days will cover the landscape what's
going to happen
massive food riots in the streets
violence a gallon of water would cost
more than a gallon of gas
for the past 20 years michael has
sharpened his own survival skills but to
outlast an overpopulated world with
scarce resources he believes his entire
family must become expert preppers too
and learn to live from the land
i desperately want to teach my children
everything they need to survive
investing every waking hour in what i do
leaves little if any room for making
money for college tuition for the
children but there's something that's
more important than that today uh we're
gonna wake up the kids and bring them
out to the woods for the whole day see
where their skill level's at develop it
to the point where i'm comfortable that
they can survive all day
hey boys
come on the day started without you
let's go we're going out in the woods no
school today
all right my middle child ryan of the
three he's the one who walks furthest
from my path it's important to have
every member of the family on board if
we are to survive as a family
the world's population rises by over 200
000 people every single day
michael believes this rapid increase
will cause massive food and water
shortages so his survival plan is
dependent on getting back to the basics
the key to our survival is that we
become that hunter-gatherer
come on ryan
i am so thirsty
well if you're thirsty what would you do
to get water right here buddy
and get water from the sink
how about using sphagnum moss if
overpopulation caused water to become
polluted or inaccessible this ordinary
plant could save them from dehydration
it's nature's sponge what you do is you
grab a whole bunch of it
and usually it's you can squeeze it
right into your mouth and get water you
want to try it
you need to know how to do this so you
can keep
alive without water in two to three days
you're dead do you understand
two to three days yeah so you willing to
try it or what
look up
there you go
good stuff
funky flavor
well it'll keep you alive
[Music]
because the douglass live on a farm that
produces food and have 400 gallons of
water caches michael fears they can
become a target in an overpopulated
world
so he has developed his very own alarm
system to warn them of dangerous
marauders in search of provisions out
here in the rural areas people are going
to be spilling out to to take what
farmers have i'm not going to allow my
family to be a target i've had
the opportunity to play with thermal
imagery cameras motion detectors
early detection systems of all kinds
you know what i use
bird feeders
birds
alarm at the most subtle of threats
by listening to the bird alarms you have
awareness of people approaching every
bird produces a different sound and each
of their calls communicates a particular
meaning a language michael has studied
for over two decades and is now passing
on to his children
what's that
not hatch
today michael is teaching emily about
the importance of the robin's distress
call which he believes could give the
family a full five minutes to prepare
for any approaching danger
all right this one's not out but tell me
what it is because it's really important
ready
robin's alarm yeah know that one that
means somebody's coming with a lot of
angry energy okay um when you have a kid
who can hear that 300 yards away in the
den of society
their awareness is amped most preppers
stock up on firearms for self-defense
but michael does not possess guns he
believes that overpopulation would cause
ammunition to become a finite resource
and he does not want to be dependent on
it you don't need to rely on
bright shiny objects like knives and
other you know guns instead plug into
the landscape to see what it can offer
you
instead his lethal weapon of choice is
made simply from an oak tree and a
railroad spike
nice other side
excellent take it and chop it right to
the base of the head boom dakota has
practiced throwing tomahawks for over
seven years and he also has martial arts
training
today michael is combining both of these
skills to teach dakota a new tomahawk
technique that he could use to fight
potential invaders inside their home
right guiding you around
boom you're holding the blades and now
you have your your blocks your strikes
your long distance just remember
lethal
hold the blade non-lethal all right this
is
crowd control escape
this is
there's nowhere else to go but life or
death your sister and brother too young
don't share that stuff with him
one day i hope to uh be as good as he is
if not better although the tomahawk is
the most dangerous weapon on the
douglas's farm it is not the only one
like a true prepper michael always has a
plan b
this is as powerful as a shotgun really
try to take out one of these targets
a throwing stick is a handmade wooden
tool with a sharpened end when thrown
sideways it is an effective hunting
weapon for small games such as rabbits
sign arm just like a martial arts punch
it's the spinning action of this stick
that when it hits
creates all that force
you want to do throwing stick with us
no i'm good
all right go ride your bike
everybody needs this
who doesn't want their children to come
home alive
[Music]
but for michael offensive training is
not enough
he wants his kids to be ready for danger
at any moment whether they have a weapon
or not so he conducts self-defense
drills every day multiple times a day
and often without warning my kids are in
there playing right now so
what i want to do
is uh give them kind of an awareness
drill you know this is how they start to
evolve their skill sets so with that in
mind
let's go have some fun
hangs in the air hands in the air now
what do you do
both hands both hands
get on that go down
all right
all right good not bad
yeah not not bad for two years
i get moments where people think that
i'm crazy or
uh too far gone all the time is it all
worth it
yeah wouldn't trade it for the world
michael douglas is determined to prepare
his entire family for an overpopulated
world
but is his reluctant 12 year old son
ryan ready
right so are you up for it i guess sorry
i i want to know not i guess so yes or
no next
michael puts him to the prepping test of
his life three
two
one
michael james patrick douglas is
preparing for overpopulation to decimate
our planet's resources and change the
way we live forever
200 people are born every single minute
worldwide so michael spends countless
hours each day preparing his children
for an overcrowded world but not all of
them are following in his prepping
footsteps ryan when he kind of drags his
feet and hangs behind his brother and
sister
it's so hard to not get frustrated
if my family is going to survive
everybody needs to be on board
hey little man
can i talk
yeah
today michael is having a father-son
talk with his 12-year-old son ryan
he believes it is time for him to be put
to the ultimate family test
i've been uh thinking about your rite of
passage the rite of passage that my
children go through is recognizing that
they have the essential skills in order
to survive the two key things for your
rite of passage are going to be your
shelter and your fire if overpopulation
causes food and water shortages michael
believes his family may have to seek out
resources further from home but hunting
and gathering on foot during the main
winter when temperatures can reach 50
below zero could be life-threatening
without shelter you succumb to
hypothermia if i do is do i get a price
yeah the prize is that you're able to
survive
i need to know all the different skills
that he teaches me
like for the food
pizza fire
matches
water
sink
i'm drinking out of moss all right so
are you up for it uh i guess sorry i i
want to know not i guess so yes or no
yes
all right
come on let's go
it is absolutely vital that ryan learned
how to build shelter it is the first
priority in physical survival michael
wants ryan to build a shelter without
relying on store-bought prepping tools
instead he'll have to use just what he
can find in the woods a lot of preppers
get so infatuated with new toys they're
temporary conveniences that will
eventually rust fall apart break get
lost we're gonna need some ribbing so
gather these stout branches okay
as many as you can get
first step is to set up your ridge pole
and then we'll put the ribs on what we
need to do is create a tripod
interlocking these fork sticks together
ryan and michael are building a debris
hut a small shelter that can be
assembled in almost any location and
works by insulating human body heat
under hundreds of layers of leaves
all of this debris is to keep your body
heat close to you so we want the inside
to be really tight and small
once you get enough leaves you're going
to be able to stay warm well below
freezing and nothing but a pair of
shorts and a t-shirt
inchworm yourself in knowing that
shelters like this could one day save
his life michael spends an average of 40
nights a year constructing and sleeping
in debris huts okay here we go he can
assess how weatherproof they are with
one simple foolproof test three
two
one
any leaks or drips
no
come on out let's see what you look like
[Music]
not bad little man good job
ryan has successfully proved that he can
build a shelter but to complete his rite
of passage he will have to show his dad
that he can create light warmth and heat
to cook the day's hunt
he'll have to make a fire when you can
manifest fire off the landscape you
don't have to worry about oil fire
equals cooked food light warmth
ryan must start a fire using only a bow
drill and a piece of notched wood all
items that can be easily made from the
natural environment don't give up now
you're doing it
you got a coal
check it out check it out okay buddy
stay calm should come here here i want
to dump it carefully into your gender
bundle very very gently squeeze the
sides of the tinder bundle like a taco
okay blow hard
blow harder
through it through it
dude you got fire little man all right
good job
that's your fire
that's a good fight
you're entering a new stage of your life
you're no longer a little kid anymore
turning into a young man
this here
is your umbilical cord
when the douglas children prove they can
survive an overpopulated world
they are presented with their own
umbilical cord which has been preserved
in cedar wood and sweetgrass since their
birth represents your attachment to me
and mom
but today you proved that you're a
survivor
and that you're ready to take the next
step so i'm giving it to you
signifies that you're your own person
right now
all right these abilities that you
showed me today are proof that you are a
survivor
i hope you pursue it because our
family's counting on you
when it hits the fan our family's plan
is not to survive but to sir thrive
michael the experts practical preppers
believe that being accustomed to living
off the land puts you way ahead of the
preparedness curve it will be invaluable
to you and your family
however given the climate in maine we
are concerned what food you are able to
grow during the winter months
the point about our food shortcomings
through winter spot on
since the departure of the natgeo film
crew we've emphasized endurance training
strength training
and conditioning to include
acclimatization in harsh environments
while the earth's population has more
than doubled since 1959 the united
nations predicts that growth will begin
to slow in the next century and level at
10 billion by the year 2100
real estate developer larry hall is
building luxury survival condos
guaranteed to help you and your family
survive everything from solar flares to
a polar shift if you can afford the
million dollar price tag joe that is a
water tank
[Music]
larry hall is an engineer turned real
estate developer
his latest investment property is
located on the picturesque plains of
kansas
a luxury condominium complex complete
with a gym pool and a movie theater
hey joe the water tank is coming good
yeah i've been around uh the building
industry my whole life i've built
everything from uh residential
properties up through it including
high-tech uh military and industrial
applications
see we got concrete in the hall see that
that's a milestone man it's been a long
time coming
but larry's not building a normal condo
complex
i'm building a luxury survival
condominium to protect against solar
flare worldwide economic collapse or
anything mother nature can throw at us
something's going on things aren't as
normal as they were and so that caused a
great concern for me
the survival condo project is a
one-size-fits-all solution
to solar flares and loss of the grid
avian bird flu you know nuclear
explosion earthquakes volcanic eruptions
when complete this 14-story high-rise
will protect up to 70 preppers within
its walls including larry himself
i've got a family i have a wife and a
six-year-old son
when you become a parent suddenly you
aren't the most important thing anymore
it makes me feel responsible
in in having to prepare for to protect
his condo residents from the devastation
and social chaos that he believes could
follow anything from a solar flare to
nuclear war larry has hidden the entire
condo complex completely from sight you
don't want it to be a convenient target
for
possible marauders or population centers
to be attracted to so this high-rise is
not being built up it's being built down
you know it's a 14-story building
embedded in nine foot of concrete 175
feet into the ground
and this is no ordinary hole in the
ground it is a former nuclear missile
silo built in the 1960s at the height of
the cold war
this was designed to house an
intercontinental ballistic missile that
was capable of reaching the soviet union
it was designed to open and lift the
missile to the surface where it could
then be launched
this formidable concrete shell was
designed to withstand a direct nuclear
strike and can take 100 pounds of
pressure per square inch which is
equivalent to a storm with over 1500
mile per hour winds
there's some 600 tons of reinforcing
steel in this structure
so if there were a super tornado out
here
life would be uninterrupted for the
survivalists that would be inside here
in larry's condos you're supposed to
feel like you are on vacation not like
you're surviving doomsday
we've got a swimming pool we've got
exercise rooms we have a library and
classroom we've got a movie theater
we've got a barn lounge in here
but luxury comes at a price larry has
sunk three million dollars in counting
into this large hole to ensure that his
preppers get only the best we have
dual fuel ranges high-end countertop
materials bamboo renewable wood floors
but believing that anything from an
economic collapse to a pandemic could
threaten basic services like food water
and electricity larry has customized
many prepper specific extras to ensure
the post-apocalyptic survival of his
clients
some of the features that we've had to
design into the survival condominium
that you would not see in a normal
building include redundancy for key life
support structures like redundant water
systems
this morning on my way into
the water tank manufactured
the average american uses a staggering
100 gallons of water each day enough to
fill 1600 drinking glasses
so if an earthquake tsunami or nuclear
war caused the country's water supply
systems to break down larry has a backup
plan
wow
now joe that is a water tank that's what
you ordered planned on furnishing with
several drinks of water and i believe
that'll do the job
the 25 000 gallons of water stored in
these tanks is enough to fill a small
swimming pool and if rationed larry
believes it will allow his 70 prepper
residents to survive safely cocooned in
the missile shaft for several months
with the threats that are out there a
lot of these investors really wanted to
have 25 000 gallons as a minimum buffer
and this gives them a reservoir that's
independent of everything else
regardless of what happens to any other
supply so it'll probably be ready for
installation within the next couple
weeks that puts a lot of minds at ease
the people in the united states are so
used to this machine that we call our
society being able to provide for them
and when that machine breaks people get
desperate people get hungry and that
escalates the snowball of civil unrest
worried that his luxury condos will
become a post-apocalyptic target larry
has devised a half a million dollar
four-stage security plan
stage one is a seven foot high perimeter
fence that will act as an initial
barrier to ward off attackers
harry there i just see this gate move on
its own finally yes you just made my day
it's only taken what three weeks now
you want those i'm sure
i do want these make sure you push the
right button the large the large you
made it idiot proof for me wow perfect
i'm not sure we can solve that problem
security stage 2 is a complex
surveillance system that monitors both
the perimeter and interior of the
underground complex and is designed to
alert residents to any break-in of the
site we're going to put state-of-the-art
electronics we have a fingerprint
scanner biometric system motion sensors
throughout the whole facility there'll
be cameras everywhere there'll be more
cameras probably than
the white house i don't know
if the outer defenses are breached by
attackers stage three is the protruding
entrance of the missile silo itself
you're shooting at a concrete structure
that's nine feet thick you're gonna run
out of ammunition
and if anyone is determined enough to
get through stages one two and three
larry's last line of defense is his own
army of preppers the 70 battle ready
residents of his condo the exact
quantity of weapons that we have is
covered by some confidentiality
agreements but we have everything from
handguns
shotguns to automatic rifles we have
ammo well in excess of tens of thousands
of rounds so we could fight a small war
larry has thought through every detail
of apocalypse living but none of it
means anything if he can't make a sale
next larry takes a potential resident on
the home tour of her life well now that
you've seen it
how do you feel about your interest
level
on the windy plains of kansas real
estate developer and engineer larry hall
is building a luxury apartment building
for an unusual clientele
preppers
who want to escape the end of the world
the people that are contacting us are
concerned about a global economic
collapse a terrorist threat the climate
change wiping out the majority of our
food production a pole ship a meteorite
or comet strike we've gotten everything
here and uh this facility is not just a
single event type thing
but to buy your way out of the
apocalypse you'll need spare change to
the tune of one or two million dollars
the price of a palatial six-bedroom
mansion in kansas city
today we have a prospective buyer that's
our first visit to the site we're going
to show her where we are in the
construction process
sarah is a suburban mom living in
central kansas today she is driving to
larry's missile site to see if doomsday
luxury is all it's cut out to be you
can't ignore everything from the weather
changes whether they be natural cycles
or whether they be something more
serious
i think it's just the beginning of what
we're looking at because of security
concerns sarah has requested that her
identity not be revealed on camera
a lot of the people that are interested
in this project want to be somewhat
anonymous so certainly they don't want
to be filmed
my worst case scenario would would be a
nuclear war or biological war i'm
wanting to put myself and my family in
an environment that we will be as safe
as possible
many americans can identify with sarah's
sense of impending dread a recent poll
found that 41 of americans feel that
preparing for a disastrous event is more
important than saving for retirement and
over half believe some kind of
catastrophic event will occur in the
next 10 years hi sarah hi you ready to
see the project i am ready to see the
project i've read about it now it's time
to see it great i'm glad you're here
let's go inside
with over three million invested in this
project and a potential two million
dollar sale riding on this meeting the
stakes for larry are high
we have seven residential levels we've
got a movie theater and a bar and a
lounge down here sarah is eager to know
exactly how much she will have to give
up for the apocalypse now some some of
the luxuries that i guess in a in a
lockdown situation you would expect to
give up would be cable internet
satellite tv
you're the first person computer
internet you're the first person how am
i going to log into my facebook
well
actually we have some specialized
servers that keep snapshots of web pages
on the internet right okay
are you ready to go see the units i am
let's go take a look
this is a formidable door inside larry's
condos life is set up to feel as normal
as possible in spite of the end of days
raging outside on this way watch your
step
every tenant in larry's building will go
to work each day the normalcy of your
day-to-day operations is important
because everyone in here would have to
work a minimum of four hours a day with
the regular preventative maintenance and
manning the security desks and things
like that and on the way back to their
condo they can stop off at the local
supermarket to pick up their groceries
the level that we're on here this is the
general store and it'll it'll be set up
like a general store you'll see sundries
around and there'll be it allows you to
still feel like you're you're going to
the store on your way home from work to
grab what you're fixing for dinner
exactly you're actually socializing and
going through the same motions that you
would normally normally okay
we have a combination of freeze-dried
and dehydrated food sources
60 months per person which is five years
and that's on about a 2500 calorie per
day calculation so that's a pretty
formidable food reserve by itself
now this is the the highest of the seven
residential floors this also happens to
be my space that my condos being built
in in true life fashion my wife and i
haven't uh agreed on a floor plan for
our unit yet yeah i can imagine you can
see that it's a pretty big space with
the tall ceilings you don't feel exactly
all that closed in i i can you know the
10 foot that extra the vertical real
estate exactly we consulted with some
psychologists that um gave us some
really useful advice
to how to prevent um getting cabin fever
or going stir crazy larry's ceilings are
two feet higher than the standard eight
feet seen in most american homes and
research has shown that just this small
difference can actually make people feel
less constrained and even happier you
know it's a very comfortable space and
though larry's prepper condos are 175
feet underground his buyers still have a
choice of view to consider the
artificial windows will be really fun
larry's electronic windows can look out
on any view you want can i be on a beach
on a beach okay you could be at san
francisco harbor you could live in an
aquarium you could live on the space
station okay all right
but will larry's extensive food water
and security preps sell sarah on the
apocalyptic dream
well now that you've seen it and you
have a an appreciation for what's
involved here um how do you feel about
your interest level uh honestly my
interest level is up quite a bit you
know i need to discuss with my family i
think it's important for me to let you
know that i have at least 12 people that
are in an active state of question and
answers that high interest levels being
driven by the threats that we're seeing
in the world right now everything seems
to be picking up so what's what pushed
me to this point this fast so i can
understand that you're not alone
at the end of another 14-hour long day
on site larry and his construction team
are finally taking the time to crack
open a beer and discuss their own fears
about the end of days i think the solar
flares are the worst threat you're
losing a big part of the power grid is
what would deteriorate on so many levels
people do not know how to take care of
themselves anymore they are totally
dependent upon
the city the state the government things
can get bad really quick it's what
scares me the most you know what
wouldn't you do to protect your family
you would you would do things that you
wouldn't normally do
that's scary to think about the fact
that you might exactly the answer is be
prepared because you don't want to deal
with the alternative so
well set that's where we're at very well
said
[Music]
larry the experts think your facility is
extremely well prepped and anyone who is
able to secure a unit will have better
peace of mind in case of a catastrophic
event
okay however you should think about
recruiting inhabitants with advanced
skill sets including those with medical
and military training i agree 100 with
that comment we we attempted to do just
that but given the economic conditions
that we have today
that option became overcome by events
for lack of a better term
since that geo is here we've had five
offers for purchasing various units
we're getting a lot of activity in that
area of the project and we hope to close
some videos pretty soon
becky brown believes that the united
states government will declare martial
law and take away basic human rights
from all american citizens
she has spent fifty thousand dollars
prepping in fear of a government
takeover
but how prepared is she
becky brown is a thirty-something living
in salt lake city where she is in her
last semester of business school oh hey
oh hey guys thanks for coming
so i thought that for today's study
group that we could talk about something
we haven't talked much about which is
the government is not doing very well
right now a big portion of the public in
the u.s is unemployed
because of our nation's high
unemployment rate becky believes that
the economy will collapse causing the
government to forcibly take over and
declare martial law which would
dismantle democracy and strip american
citizens of their basic constitutional
rights regular citizens have no idea
what's going on i just study things and
put the clues together and go hmm i
foresee the government takeover
happening within the next year or two
honestly
i think that we have more problems in
our government as a whole right now than
ever before
they could literally come in with the
army call martial law the city would
look like chaos the highways and the
roads will be shut off because they're
gonna mandate who goes where
we won't have a water supply they're
gonna hold the water for the most elite
we're gonna be left surviving on our own
with what we have already we'll know
when the government takeover has
happened when they actually knock on
your door
and it's gonna come by surprise and then
we'll wake up the next morning going i
should have bought some food storage
i've spent close to fifty thousand
dollars prepping thirty thousand in the
last year i probably spend about four
hours a day
thinking about prepping that has
prevented me from
being in a long-term relationship when
i'm not in school i spend all day every
day prepping that's all i do
becky's preparations influence all
facets of her life including her current
location
she looked at several apartments and
finally settled on her present home
i chose to live in this house
particularly because the capitol is
literally right in my backyard having
the capital right behind me is a
constant reminder
that the government could declare
martial law and take over the city so
it's
a blessing that i'm living so close to
be able to put the clues together
many preppers do not disclose they have
emergency supplies in fear of becoming a
target but becky believes that
collaboration is key to surviving a
government takeover so she's invited her
close friends isaac and spencer and new
acquaintance victoria for an informal
gathering you guys know that i'm into
prepping
right
and so um
i just wanted to invite you over to try
and
show you what i have i'm afraid for my
friends that don't prep i have been
thinking about preparing but i just
haven't ever done anything about it i i
see that the government's getting more
and more control
and
i honestly think that they'll probably
end up being
martial law government takeover declared
you kind of have to have a backup plan
thought out ahead of time i'm really
concerned about my friends and family
and
you know i i just want you guys to be
prepared too
so you want to see what i have yeah
okay
yeah becky lives in an 1800 square foot
apartment
and has a 200 square foot room dedicated
entirely to her preps
the room holds nearly 100 gallons of
water and over 4 000 servings of
long-term food if the government takes
over
we're going to run out of food the
trucks are going to stop moving the
trucks stop moving in the country we're
not going to be able to get the food
from the farms to the stores
so we're going to be stuck you're going
to need food storage and this stuff is
awesome they come in mylar bags
mylar bags are commonly used in prepping
because they create a strong barrier
against oxygen allowing dehydrated foods
to be stored for up to 20 years becky
has 800 of these bags stowed away in
what she calls grab-and-go buckets with
one of these grab-and-go buckets away 17
pounds you know just check it out
if you had to run with one of those that
would feed you for about two months one
person run with this who knows if they
were to show up on our front doorstep
and say okay you no longer live here
becky believes that if martial law were
declared thousands of salt lake city
residents would attempt to escape at the
same time which would make highways
impassable and force them to travel by
foot you will be on foot at one time or
another it's it's gonna be really
important to have something
turn around spencer bug out bag is also
known as a 72-hour kit so if you have to
bug out or
get out of town you have a backup plan
most preppers consider bug out bags a
necessity and they are typically packed
with food water and first aid supplies
because becky fears a takeover could
happen at any time having won is simply
not enough i have several bug out bags
my big bug out bag usually stays at home
but i have smaller ones that i keep in
my car anywhere i go i always have that
safety net take breaks unless you're
being chased
but that would that would give you
enough supplies for 72 hours
i could run maybe
about 50 feet with that yeah becky
believes that the lack of resources
available on a government takeover will
incite civil unrest so self-protection
will be as important as having food and
water
so you can imagine that when the
government takes over you're guarding
your family you're guarding your
resources you're guarding your food and
water people are gonna want to get at it
that don't have it my intent isn't to
scare you it's just to prepare you so if
you don't have a gun
then you can get something like this
i mean it's pretty easy go like that and
you know it can put them out for about
five minutes
becky stun gun works using only a 9-volt
battery and can incapacitate an attacker
by shocking them with up to 150 000
volts of electricity that's a lot of
electricity going through there i
thought it was illegal it's not
she's always trying to convince other
people to get into what she's doing i
hope they'll realize the value in it
and start preparing on their own
i was very overwhelmed by the intensity
of her preparedness but it made a lot
more sense to me as it went on
with only a non-lethal weapon how will
becky protect herself and her preps
effectively and what will the experts
think
becky brown has spent fifty thousand
dollars preparing for a hostile
government takeover in which she
believes ordinary citizens will be
deprived of basic necessities she has
five years of food storage and is
prepping her friends for added support
but how will she defend her provisions
from the violence she expects
salt lake city had over 13 000 property
crimes in 2010 becky fears that figure
will only rise in a government takeover
as those who did not prepare take from
those who did
to safeguard her preps becky is starting
security training with her friend a
professional contract sniper whose
identity must be concealed due to the
high risk nature of his occupation
so
bob let's call him he used to work in
iraq
protecting officials he's been in a lot
of rough situations what kind of
situation we talking about we're talking
about like civil unrest kind of thing
yeah like if the government takes over
what kind of weapons do you have yeah
that's what i was going to show you
a stun gun is a non-lethal weapon that
can only be used in close proximity when
the electrodes are pressed against the
attacker that'll do the trick
if somebody is right in your face and on
top of you right okay
but
the the key to this is you don't want to
get that close okay if intruders broke
into becky's home in search of food and
water her stun gun would only protect
her temporarily and only as far as she
could reach
how about this okay a poker okay we're
getting someplace now i would definitely
use it as a club
okay okay so swap yeah not swat hit em
like a home run okay okay across the
head bob is scary sometimes i know he's
trying to make me better but it makes me
nervous bring all your weight down
like that it's a good start we're gonna
have to get you a firearm so you don't
have to worry about this okay i don't
have a gun i'm a girl i'm feminine i'm
not supposed to love guns right but you
get in a different mentality
when you're protecting your family and
your home and the things that are most
important to you
an estimated 17 million women own or
carry a firearm and although becky's not
one of them today she is taking bob's
advice and is learning how to defend
herself with a lethal weapon
when the government takes over i will
need to know how to shoot a gun i will
need to protect my food and my water
kill an animal or to defend my friends
and my family from predators of any sort
just line your sights up you want to
concentrate on the front sight just
squeeze the trigger don't jerk the
trigger move your hand and grab it like
that no no no shoot with your dominant
eye but leave both eyes open
can you do that no
[Music]
no
not yet
okay we'll work on that you're gonna
have to learn to do that yeah i can't do
that a hand pistol is ideal for engaging
an enemy in close quarter combat when
used with quick accurate fire
but in a government takeover becky
believes she will need offensive as well
as defensive weapons so if necessary she
can preemptively eliminate a threat
without being detected
today with bob's expertise she is
training with a bolt action sniper rifle
outfitted with a telescopic lens that
guarantees optimal precision from up to
1 000 yards away
i'm taking sniper training
because then i could keep people as far
away from me as i needed to this hand
goes underneath you support it
okay make a fist
pull it tight into your shoulder you
want me to have it dead center
vertically right
today becky's bullseye is 200 yards the
equivalent of two football fields
you hit it did i yes sweet
hit
three for three
at 200 yards
not quite five for five i got three out
of five if there's a government takeover
i need to be five for five so i need to
improve on that we're going to need all
of this if and when this happens
becky the experts practical preppers
commend you for training with a weapons
expert and trying to involve other
people in your prepping
however if you have to leave salt lake
city within a matter of minutes it will
be difficult to carry your supplies
that's why i have a big frame
hiking backpack and so that's the thing
that i would take if i were on foot also
they advise that you create a water
filtration system in case your city's
water supply becomes compromised i
totally agree that i need more water i'm
working on that your food storage is
adequate for yourself but not for your
friends keep pushing them to make sure
they are prepared i have enough food
storage for myself because that's who
i'm planning for
i agree also that i need to teach my
friends because friends can quickly
become enemies if you're in a hostile
situation
while martial law has been declared
intermittently throughout american
history it has not happened at a
national level in the modern age
this constitutional power has only been
used on small scales to regain order
during an extreme crisis
such as hurricane katrina when local
governance broke down
[Music]
you